[Music]
today thank you so much for coming in
thank you for having us review yeah we
listen the matte painting that we do
here that Collider is fantastic a high
def high def screen you've got yeah we
don't mess around at Collider on matte
paintings we learned from Lucasfilm you
know all the painting anyway so I want
to start by saying I saw the first two
episodes of the show and I thought they
were fantastic so well done production
design acting cinematography it's just
one of these really really well done
shows and I want to get into all that
but it's so I think the show is so
timely and it's dealing with and I know
it's very personal to George but I think
it's just such a timely show with what's
going on in the country and I wanted to
know if you could sort of talk about
that absolutely I mean it just makes it
just makes the drama that much more
compelling it ups the stakes and you
know a big hats off to the entire
production team that we're so dedicated
to the authenticity and the research of
you know everything that happened and
the costumes and the hair and everything
and it's just it made it so much more
important for all of us on set you know
we're we're telling an important story
but we're we're creating drama at the
same time that I think is gonna really
grip a lot of audiences especially of
the horror genre yeah I mean this
happened 70 75 years ago and many people
doesn't even know that this happened you
know like many people are not aware even
when I cast for this role I didn't even
know this happened and we're just
repeating history you know we're just
doing it again and again and again and
we need to learn what we have done
before in order to change that you know
so I think it's it's a great moment
obviously to tell this story is and I
think people are gonna feel connected to
every single character
well as Christina says this is still a
story that's little-known and so we
actually this series I see as a hopeful
series because if people know this story
and they learn about it while they're
very young
it you know that's the age when people
are absorbing in information and they'll
keep it through the rest of their lives
the fact that we we have adults today
that don't know this story reflects on
the nature of our population American
population and that's why it's happening
again
I'm hopeful because when this happened
to us every politician in fact the whole
country was swept up with war hysteria
and prejudice against us we looked like
the people that bombed Pearl Harbor but
when Trump passed that wrote of a sign
that Muslim travel ban thousands of
young Americans rushed to their airports
all over the country to protest that
travel ban and lawyers went to the
airports to offer their services pro
bono to immigrants coming in and the
Deputy Attorney General of the United
States Sally Yates said she will not
defend this executive order so Americans
have learned about it but not enough
Americans and by presenting this story
as an entertainment and compelling
spine-tingling
entertainment more people will know
about it and my hope and I think the
hope of the show is that the more
Americans that know about this story
that outnumber the kind of people who
support our current administration our
hope is that this won't happen they will
vote against it more and more people are
learning about the japanese-american
internment as demonstrated by the
reaction to
Trump's Muslim travel ban and hopefully
because this is such a new low that
we've reached when children are being
torn away from their parents and put in
cages living wallowing in filth their
own excrement I mean it's disgusting
and with enough Americans now will know
that this must not be happening in our
name as Americans Americans are better
than this
I completely agree 100% with what you
said I also think that you know a lot of
times people for example like Holocaust
movies or Holocaust stories I think
those should be told every year to just
keep on drilling down that this happened
in the past and we need to always
remember and I'm you know thankful that
this chapter in our history is being
told as you said you know using
entertainment to sort of tell the story
I am curious though making a show like
this what's the energy like I'm gonna
switch gears a little bit what is the
energy like on set making something like
this like was this a super fun shoot was
this super challenging because any
making any television show is a whole
bunch of work it was not fun
imagine yourself in Canada in January
look if you're watching arts a
challenging look cold
it was bone-chilling challenge our bones
were chilled to the marrow frozen cold
and we were filming outdoors and on a
made-up frozen lake we had to pay pet
for photos in Lake when they had real
frozen lakes all over the place it was
not fun challenging for sure but
gratifying because we're all out there
battling the elements together and we're
making a special project and everyone's
coming and bringing the their top game
because we know how great the writing is
how great the whole team is and and yeah
we were just on a mission to this is
ELISA Mabuse reality for this old man
was horrific
I am curious how how have you been
describing your character to people
because yeah like what are you allowed
to say about your character so my
character I play you go she is a
mysterious young Japanese girl who moved
to Terminal Island from Japan she has a
deep connection with this guy Chester
and Ruth and while everybody and also
Yuko is the Tara she well I had to put a
special makeup on every day three hours
before we start shooting it was really
hard for me so you also agree with
George it was a challenging shoot yeah
but it was I had so much fun though like
everybody asked me like how how like how
do you feel when you shoot horror film
like horror movies and stuff because
it's sounds scary but it wasn't really
scary like when we were shooting scary
part a family you know like yeah we
really became a family yeah that's that
makes this show so I'm so much easier I
mean you go to work every day with your
family then it's like we're having fun
we're doing this with doing what we love
and plus we're telling an amazing story
so what else can we ask for yeah the
thing I eat bro May and June it was fun
I will say though so I'm watching I want
to say it's the first episode and I had
to do a double take because I noticed
something in the background which I
wasn't expecting it in the background so
you really have to be looking is there a
lot of that in the show and I guess this
is for people that are watching watch
the background yes yes you can't you
can't take your eyes away because you
might miss something for sure is that
all throughout the series or I think
even even like not only the background
like background of you too like you have
to watch out like everything do you know
what I mean
I have to say this the scope the massive
scope of this show first of all to deal
with the story of the internment there
have been a few movies few television
shows done on it but never 10 hours over
10 episodes
that's aired over a 10-week period and
the detail with which the story was told
this was an impressive production and
I'm I think we're all proud to be
associated with this this is a
groundbreaking production as I said I I
mean in all seriousness I thought it
looked fantastic just everything about
it in terms of the way the story is
being brought to life my last thing for
each of you guys because I'm already
basically out of time but what's like a
day or two that you will always remember
from the making of this project whether
it be a super challenging day on set or
whether it be just an awesome day for
whatever reason the day I'll remember is
the the they built a whole internment
camps many many barracks about a quarter
of normal internment camps with the
barbed wire fence and at all
ominous sentry Tower and there were
hundreds of Japanese Canadians and
Chinese Canadians and Korean Canadians
as extras massive numbers of Asian
people holding carrying their suitcases
and and duffle bags and other packages
and all marching into that internment
camp or we were that was a day we were
freed I think going out from the barbed
wire fence and in that shot I just kept
looking at this sentry Tower because I
remember that as a scary place where
people were aiming rifles at you that
scene was massive
and it was done on again on this huge
scale hundreds of extras yeah that was
powerful I mean there's so there's so
many things I wish I could say one but
it's it's a huge spoiler yeah that's I
won't say that one but I think I mean
the cold weather we we shot actually it
snowing like it was knowing any wood we
were shooting you know so that was and
you wouldn't you wouldn't have you would
only have a jacket accused I mean it
didn't have enough money to have more
you know so that was tough that was
tough but you would always have to
remember that someone went through this
someone lived this and just use that to
really show it you know and people feel
connected to it I was yeah back to back
to the weather when we're trying to
depict you know hot summer and it just
starts dumping snow on you I've never
experienced that before but we all we
all weathered the elements and created
something fantastic of high quality that
everyone's gonna enjoy I completely
agree I really mean it's C really cannot
wait to finish the show thank you so
much for coming by our matte painting
and and seriously enjoy comic-con thank
you so much thank you